Speaker 1: Hey, David, what would happen if
you abolished the minimum wage?
OK, so this there's been a lot of talk about
a 15 dollar minimum wage lately.
And we learned last week that Chipotle, in
order to account for paying 15 bucks an hour,
is raising prices four percent, which is a
really, really modest increase.
It's like 26 cents on your average chicken
burrito, even though everybody will earn fifteen
dollars an hour.
And there are some sort of libertarian right
wing types who say, listen, the minimum wage
is an artificial price floor and it is simply
a bad it's a price control.
It's bad for the economy.
It keeps people out of the workforce if you
eliminated the minimum wage.
Sure.
Wages might come down a little bit, but way
more people would end up becoming employed.
And that would be good for the economy because
then they would pay taxes and little.
OK, first of all, if you saw a decrease to
the minimum wage, that's significant and it
led to more employment.
A lot of those people, because the wage would
be so low, would would not or would barely
pay any federal taxes.
So in reality, the tax thing may even be be
wrong, number one.
Number two, we have a counterexample to this.
OK, the value of the minimum wage.
Remember, if you have a seven dollar minimum
wage and you have inflation, the value of
that minimum wage actually goes down if you're
the employer.
And there is inflation, meaning your product
or service sells for more, but you pay the
same nominal minimum wage, you are actually
seeing a decrease to the minimum wage in real
terms.
We had a situation in the 1980s where the
minimum wage, the actual value of the minimum
wage went down about a third because of inflation.
And we actually saw teen employment drop site
slightly.
This is the big claim from the right.
All of these teenagers and entry level workers
and what we call less skilled workers, they
would have way more employment if the minimum
wage were to go down.
Well, the minimum wage did go down in real
terms during the 1980s and significantly so
just under a third, 32 percent.
I believe the number is.
And you did not see teen employment explode
because it all of a sudden became really cheap
to hire people.
It got cheaper for businesses to hire because
of that stagnant minimum wage.
And they didn't.
And as I've said so many times before, when
it comes to taxation and hiring and the minimum
wage, if a business is understaffed relative
to the demand for their product or service,
then it would make sense to go and add a new
worker.
And if you can get that worker for less, well,
even better for the business, I guess.
But it's not profitable to just add workers
because it's cheaper to add them.
It doesn't make sense.
Think about it.
You know, with The David Pakman Show, if we
actually have a an unmet need, either because
we have so much demand for advertising that
I need more salespeople or we have so much
demand for memberships that I need to bring
on a full time web developer to keep up with
the website traffic or whatever the case may
be.
Just because it becomes cheaper to hire someone
doesn't mean I'm actually going to go and
hire someone unless I'm servicing demand.
Now, what would actually increase demand?
And this is where the right just kind of seems
to not not get it or pretend not to get it.
What would increase demand for membership's?
It would be people having more money.
And one way to put more money in the pockets
of people who might only borderline be able
to afford a membership right now would be
a minimum wage increase.
Now, I think there are some fair assessments
about the minimum wage that come from the
right.
One is most people don't make minimum wage,
and because wages tend to be sticky, wages
don't tend to come down.
If you got rid of the minimum wage, it's unlikely
that most people's wages would come down.
If you're in a job where you make the equivalent
of 25 bucks an hour, it might be twenty five
bucks an hour or it might just be a fifty
thousand dollar a year salary.
Right.
If the minimum wage went down or even was
eliminated, it's not hugely likely, at least
right away, that you would end up earning
less money.
But there is a particularly vulnerable class
of workers, particularly when we're talking
about immigrants, talking about people in
disadvantaged neighborhoods that already often
have the sort of structural disadvantages
of terrible public transit and so on and so
forth.
Those are the first folks who are going to
be taken advantage of.
And there's going to be this downward pressure.
And the whole point of the minimum wage is
not to insure everybody makes 50 grand a year.
That would require a twenty five dollar minimum
wage at every job in many states that are
low cost of living it.
That's not a it's just not an equilibrium
wage.
And I know there's many people who say the
minimum wage should be twenty five bucks an
hour.
You know, in rural Alabama, a twenty five
dollar an hour minimum wage is out of equilibrium
with business, profitability and cost of living
in some big cities.
That probably is the right minimum wage.
But the point here is you are going to see
the most disadvantaged and those with the
least market power to advocate for themselves
taking advantage of now, the right will then
come back in and say, well, they can then
organize and they can all agree we're not
going to work for less than X, and they can
push prices up and demand to be paid more.
That's what unions do now.
And those same right wingers are against the
unions and they're against collective bargaining
and on and on and on.
So you really have to step back from the talking
points on this.
If you eliminate the minimum wage, is it likely
that a lot of people would start working for
50 cents an hour?
No, that's not likely.
But the federal minimum wage is already pathetic.
And what the other thing, by the way, that's
important to remember is reducing the minimum
wage will shift the burden of paying people
away from businesses and towards the government.
If you reduce the minimum wage, you're also
basically setting up a bigger government handout
and subsidy because the benefits and welfare
programs that individuals will start to qualify
for if you scrap the minimum.
Wage and you see somewhat of a reduction,
you know, seven, 25, maybe some people start
working for six or five dollars an hour for
fifty or whatever, the the fact that more
people will work, which doesn't appear to
be true.
But even if it were true, more people will
work.
If you reduce the minimum wage, they whatever
they pay in to the government, you will lose
because they will qualify for government welfare
programs that cost the government money that
come out of taxes anyway.
So the point of the minimum wage is let's
agree and establish some minimum that makes
sense based on cost of living, based on equilibrium
wages, based on what we consider to to be
a reasonable standard to set.
We're not talking about a fifty dollar an
hour, one hundred dollars an hour minimum
wage, and it should be in balance with the
broader economy and prevent the most vulnerable
from being taken advantage of.
That's really the point.
And the hypotheses about, well, if more money
is good, pay people 100 bucks, or if you get
rid of the minimum wage, people will be working
for 10 cents an hour.
You're focusing on the the extremes and you're
really sort
of missing the big picture